taste buddies
no press fleshers that means you're no
press for life body and soul
we got road dates coming up not together
separately
but you know look
hopefully they're on separate weekends
and you can see both of us
and if we're on the same weekend in your
town you're gonna have to make a choice
i don't know what to tell you
but i'll be at helium
comedy club in buffalo uh january 27th
28th 29th i'm going to be at bananas in
new jersey
uh the 4th and 5th of february i'm going
to be at the punch line in philadelphia
march 10th 11th and 12th and i'm going
to be
at
uh in austin texas at the creek and cave
uh the 20th and 21st of may and there's
some other dates and things that are
popping up that i'm not allowed to
announce yet but will be coming soon
to a city near you
guys just come see me i'm in a bad way
you know i mean you can hear it i can't
i can't remember my website name
uh i'll see you out there
jodarossainfo.com for all tickets uh
links and and show info and all that
good stuff will be there what's up guys
it's a new year i'm on the road it's
been a while please come out and see me
everything on
savilecanocomedy.com as far as tickets
go i'm gonna be in san diego i'm gonna
be in los angeles uh burlington vermont
uh foxwoods and then uh further into
february detroit we have two shows on
february 11th pittsburgh two shows on
february 12th albany two shows on
february 18th tysons virginia were there
on the 19th two shows in madison on
february 26th two shows at the vic in
chicago i'm so excited about that on
february 27th right now chrissy d and i
will also be at the ryman auditorium in
nashville on march 11th i am going to be
adding dates and cities all the time all
on salvolcanocomedy.com i've been having
a blast on the road i'm excited to come
see you guys go to the website check me
out i'll see you soon
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but
howdy folks welcome to
t-a-s-t-e
buzz
today's battle is nachos versus sushi or
sushi versus nachos i don't know how
pimp listed it on the video thing here
because we're not that far yet but it's
gonna be a hell of a fight a hell of a
fight i hear the people already i hear
saying what are you doing we don't like
this match up what how could you compare
those two sushi versus nachos this makes
no sense good good try guys these
battles
i hear i anticipated i hear you all and
i'm here to tell you now
we created the show we do what we want
we understand why we're doing it
sometimes
it's not enough to just compare two
things that are kind of similar
sometimes it's natural opponents
sometimes we do things that are similar
but sometimes those things are too
similar to the point where it doesn't
really make sense because there's no big
division what we realized recently
is we've run the gamut on a lot of
things that have natural opposites and
what we want to focus on now sometimes
are things that you would never know who
would win they're in completely two
different camps it's hard to put odds
makers it's not to put odds on it the
odds makers would have a tough time
there are two things that are great in
their own right but they don't
necessarily have a pure connection i
think in that respect this type of thing
is a pure battle when we thought of it
at first i said i don't see it you said
to me what'd you say to me i said these
are destination these are whole foods
this these are two foods where you say
how is the sushi there
or do they have good nachos or people
say let's go for sushi or like they're
like oh let's go get some nachos exactly
right and when you go to a place that is
bad of either you're like forget it
never again also they are
kind of weird because sushi has a little
bit of how would you say you know it's
it's it's a little bit more of a genetic
hua yes if i may quote the french
japanese yes i would also say this
they are they are also foods that are
indicative of a certain type of
restaurant meaning
you get nachos in two places either
places that know how to do tex-mex
correctly
or
a bar that knows how to make a plate of
nachos sushi you get in one place maybe
two either a sushi place that knows how
to do sushi correctly or perhaps
fancy
maybe you go to a fancy uh you know like
like an upper up upscale uh uh uh
quality uh uh
what am i convenience shop that does a
little sushi and additional hold on dad
that's that's
i can't wait to go against that hold on
a second i'm saying
that is all organic whatever stop and
shop that's a place where you might grab
some soup stop and shop i would not i'm
not saying the stop and shop i'm saying
a stop and shop i'm saying a type of
shout out
all right look at me you know what i'm
saying also people people have their
favorite sushi spot and their favorite
nacho spot also people are
loyal to each of those things people
they're sushi lovers and people that
would kill for nachos right so the
people that are in that camp are going
to be very very adamant of that case
let's that's why we think it'll manifest
as a very good battle with a lot of
online chatter all right let's chant
because we're going right in on this one
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you
here we go i'm going to start right out
of the gate with a little history
according to her work
nachos first appeared in 19 i don't know
who she is this is a quote from a book
but nachos first appeared in 1933
43 43 in piedras negras a small mexican
city
wow how about that so they actually oh
no it's in texas okay sorry no no it's
near the u.s military base fort duncan
in texas but it's a mexican city very
interesting that is super interesting
because fort duncan texas the birthplace
of sushi
when was sushi born
i forgot i was
go ahead read the sushi fact in the
1820s a man named hold on
hanaya yohey hanaya yohey found himself
in ido yohe is often considered the
creator of modern
nigiri sushi or at the very least its
first great marketer okay in 1824 yohei
open the first sushi stall in
ryugoku district of ido are these both
appetizers to you guys
no
no i would do either i think either can
work as a wonderful appetizer or as a
meal i would say sushi is more of a meal
sure consider it nachos no one's like
i'll have nachos for dinner you can but
at a restaurant i mean you but but i've
gone to plenty of seafood they are an
app more than a maine i've gone to
plenty of asian influences
exactly yeah but this is my point could
you even anticipate with these two
things they're beloved
i will say i've heard of people oppose
sushi because they can't wrap their head
around the raw fish thing i've never
heard of people be like i hate nachos
but i will say
there are such ardent sushi fans that i
challenge a viewer or a listener to tell
me
if they could put odds on this battle
and so i just don't want to hear
why are these two facing each other
they're facing each other because if we
start mixing it up like this you never
know who is going to take the case right
you never know sushi has beco i agree
with you sushi has become one of the
most popular international dishes over
the last century or so
damn right easy to find a sushi
restaurant anywhere in the world i agree
with that i've been overseas plenty you
ain't finding any nachos in china
they're hard to come by in amsterdam
that's true italy try to find yourself
at the plate of nachos forget it all
right here's what i'm going to do
because nachos are not mexican
traditionally they're tex mexican even
though they were invented in a mexican
city
why haven't we done that why are we
saying all the syllables
okay
okay look at me sushi i didn't eat it
until late in life maybe like my
i want to call it maybe late 20s almost
i didn't understand it it was expensive
i couldn't wrap my head around it why do
i even need these people they're just
handing me the fish as it was right
before i didn't get i didn't that i eat
it and not
violently throw up okay i then
tried sushi
i enjoyed it i got
addicted to sushi i was having sushi
three times a week for a couple of years
of my life
i've now come back around where i enjoy
sushi when i'm in the mood for it but
even
when i'm eating sushi sometimes and i
was in the mood for it
oh there's a fine line and if i slightly
over order by an extra roll or something
like that or if something is when you
have bet i don't care what you think a
bad nacho is if you take a bad bite of
raw fish
it might it might you will never have it
again i've never had it i've never i've
never had a bad piece of sushi that i
can remember that that was so bad it put
me off of it i'm at places where i said
that wasn't really worth the money i
won't go back
even when i'm having good sushi and i
ordered a little too much something when
i'm eating sushi now and again it it's
evolved for me but there's a thing in me
when i'm eating sushi now that something
can flip and if it flips i mean i'm up
shit's creek where i go
what are you eating
what are you eating you're eating raw
fish one after the other you're stuffing
your gills
with a raw nothing makes me feel prouder
of myself during the meal just healthier
temperatures
where are you getting room temperature
sushi you know what i mean it's not it's
not it's i mean it's not always it's not
always cold
it's not especially when they wrap
but even when they wrap it around like
fresh sushi rice that's a little warm
still when it's made really fresh
look all i'm saying is it's not cold
it's not hot it's just is all right and
sometimes when i get that in my hands i
almost start to like almost like like uh
i always start to like dry heave a
little bit i think you're talking out of
your ass here and here's why because
nothing i love nachos
i love nachos i never feel sick after
sushi outside of the way you could feel
sick if you ate too much of anything if
you ate a little too much of anything
you might go i had a little too much to
eat that's the worst disagree no no
that's let me finish that's the worst it
can get nachos
regret almost equaling my excitement
every time really at the end of those
nights
almost as sad as i was excited in the
beginning
i get excited i'm dead seriously i'm
dead serious there's something to like i
am stuffed and knowing that it's raw
fish that is way more disgusting than oh
my god i had pico de gallo
corn tortilla
chopped meat sour cream shredded cheese
tomato disagree i'm like okay fine i'm
full on all these wonderful foods that
won't make me feel like when i'm stuffed
on sushi i'm not tired i'm not lethargic
i'm not sitting there going how many
calories did i just eat i'm going at
least i'm full on like ginger and
something that's got some decent stuff
in it for me or whatever and a little
bit of rice
straight sodium that's not good for you
if you dip it in the strawberry dipping
soy sauce i do a low sodium soy sauce
and i won't let you judge me that's by
the way that they they got you hook line
and sinker low sodium is still way too
much sodium okay but i'm not eating a
couple of people dunk it in like it's a
dunk
on the thing and that's it you're at the
end of the day it's two teaspoons of soy
sauce i'm just saying like
i could eat nachos way more frequently
than i could eat sushi that's
interesting you can't eat sushi every
day by the way you can see you'll be
poisoned that's insane i give the best
nachos i've ever had in my life i don't
want to see him again for a week sushi
is a roll of the dice
and get a great plate of nachos no you
couldn't every time every time you have
sushi you're risking your life
try to get a good plate of nachos try to
get nachos when they don't put the
cheese sauce on it instead of the melted
cheese try to get it where there's a
decent ground beef on it instead of
[ __ ] chili that's running grease
everywhere where are you going to play
the chicken nachos that actually is
seasoning on the chicken and not just
[ __ ] like where are you going
where are you
almost everywhere joe you live in new
york if you throw a rock you can have a
decent nacho tell me your place
a lot sometimes like pizza where even it
when it's bad it's good that's true
no when it's bad it's bad no no when
sushi's bad it's bad of course i'm not
arguing that but it is way easier for
the number one international food in the
world to for you to find a decent sushi
than there is to find a decent okay what
about this travesty airport sushi deli
sushi
neither will i why would you ever get
sushi at an airport i'm not going to i
got i got three restaurants at an
airport wendy's burger king mcdonald's
that's it that's what i'm doing
i will not walk into any sushi
restaurant ever if i'm gonna eat sushi i
will find a sushi restaurant that has
overwhelmingly good uh reviews okay and
i will go to that one if i'm right
outside when i go oh you in the movie
sushi i won't just walk into one blind i
will look that one up because it's far
easier to get a really top-notch plate
to nachos then there's to get sushi
anywhere here not there you know there
sushi i don't disagree i think it's
until it isn't you understand what i'm
saying that's what nachos are not
necessarily that's not chosen to be told
to stop because you'll eat that [ __ ]
until the last bite cause every bite is
good you might feel sick that means it's
good until it isn't no no but it's when
it's done is when it isn't sushi i could
i could be two rolls in and have a roll
and a half left and i'd be like aaron
aaron i'm i'm done with the rest says
aaron says wanna nobody you never hear
or want to split a plate of sushi it's a
good point but aaron i disagree i think
sushi is one of the most communal meals
you can have
you sit at a bar you sit at that sushi
bar with a friend you get the sushi boat
you're talking to the guy the experience
of sushi where you're talking to the guy
and he's sending these things out and
they have crazy colors and there's no
doubt no doubt it's a culinary
masterpiece i've seen the documents i've
seen the documentaries but think i think
like okay nachos is a comfort food sushi
is not a comfort food
that label means something i disagree i
find sushi to be a wonderful comforting
experience sitting there
sitting with the guy i don't think it's
like i i don't think i think it's a
comfort food in the sense of this like
if you went to an italian restaurant for
that experience i think sushi dining
because nobody's getting sushi to go
really right nobody's getting sushi
delivered you get sushi at the place i
get sushi delivered all the time this
guy gets sushi delivered
about freshness from a great world about
freshness
babe if they didn't knock it out of the
park every time i wouldn't order it i
don't get it delivered i always i only
will go in for sushi case in point a lot
of people that love by the way no wonder
your sushi's warm bro you're getting it
delivered 45 minutes out sitting in some
kid's car or in the backpack of a of a
guy on a bicycle i don't you eat cold
sushi i've never heard of that it's cool
it's not cause it's in the fridge
because if it's not you're gonna die
because yes that's how it works i
understand yeah so but i'm saying you're
you're complaining about your temp on
your sush you gotta you gotta dash
you're bringing it to say something
close your eyes if you're not a
well-versed sushi person you close your
eyes i don't care what role i put in
your mouth no if i dipped it in some soy
a little ginger or if i if i dipped it
in a little wasab you're chewing and
you're like i know this is you
i but i don't even know if i'm eating
salmon i don't know right now if i'm
eating tuna i might be eating mackerel i
might be eating white fish i might first
of all disagree second of all as opposed
to what
the flavor dynamics of that mush that
they put on nachos you close your eyes i
told you if you were blindfolded you're
eating nachos or a burrito you couldn't
tell the difference [ __ ] outside of
the crowd
crispy tortillas outside of the question
are you telling me right now and you be
honest because all fans will see right
through it if you close your eyes and i
put
i put a sushi roll of tuna and a sushi
roll of salmon in your mouth and you
chew it with your eyes closed that you
will no you can't you don't get to put
it you don't get to put it in soy sauce
first i get it okay i'll give it to you
with nothing on it i'll take you will
you oh
this is like a person that told me that
they could tell the difference between
certain bottled waters it's all okay how
about the taste buddies let's talk about
noom noom you can download the app you
can go online uh noom is basically a
psychology-based approach to eating that
changes the way that you eat it's not
like a crash diet it's not anything like
that at all um they just change the way
you see food
and what we eat and how we eat it
uh you know instead of making you feel
guilty that you you you didn't follow
these strict rules or you you you didn't
weigh something correctly or you you
fell off track that's not what they do
at noom they empower you to keep going
um
and i know that everyone is feeling
pressures
uh to to be their healthiest cells on
the turn of the new year all the
unrealistic stuff that is on the
internet uh you know and no one wants to
keep their strict diet or feel like they
had to go to the gym a certain amount of
days or drink these diet products
you know um
those things we've all tried them and
we've all
failed with them and so this is a new
take on that which is interesting to me
uh
no no secret uh i don't know when this
is coming out but we're just into
january now and i am looking to lose
weight myself as we always are i'm
getting back uh to filming again now and
i got that
you know that at-home weight on me and i
actually am going to start using this
and i'm going to update you guys on my
progress and experience with it i know
that chris uh distefano tried it and and
and really really enjoyed it but i'm not
one that needs rigid guidelines to lose
weight it just doesn't work for me
and that's what they do they give you
knowledge and wisdom to empower you to
build smarter more sustainable habits
some stats here 75 percent of the users
finish the program
which is a lot and more than 60 percent
of them of the user engage with the
program and they keep the weight off for
a year or more that's me i'm a
flip-flopper my whole life i've gone up
20 down 20 up 30 down 30 up as much as
50 down as much as 50. uh and i have a
hard time keeping the weight off because
once i get there like all bets are off
so i'd rather
change my lifestyle than adhere to
strict rules um there's no need for fear
of ruining the whole program in one day
like i said you just get right back on
track all you need is 10 minutes to
check in a day there's nothing early in
the morning or taking huge chunks out of
your day so try it check it out go to
newm.com or download the new map start
building better habits for healthier
long-term results sign up for your trial
at
noom.com taste bud
not taste buds taste bud singular and
it's noom n-o-o-m.com
taste bud i love butcher box okay
butcher box high quality meats that are
ethically uh
sourced and sustainable delivered to my
door uh it's a subscription service i
can pause or cancel at any time but i
never think about meat i never think
about going and selecting meat at the
grocer i hate touching them and all the
red liquids spilling all over my hands i
don't like meal prep but butcher box
makes it all easy again they take the
guesswork out of it all they source
their meat from partners that use the
highest standards for quality
uh a hundred percent grass-fed b
free-range organic chicken wild-caught
seafood and more they're made
holistically their decisions their
sourcing decisions they keep the farmer
the planet and the animal and your
family in mind
um
i
use it all the time i love the filets
uh i get it says 8 to 14 pounds which is
so true the day i got my box delivered i
always pick it up and i'm just like i
cannot believe how much actual meat i'm
getting delivered to my door but i put
it in the freezer and
whenever i'm in the mood for a certain
type of meat i have it on hand every
month they ship a curated selection of
high quality meat to your home it's free
shipping in the continental u.s there's
no antibiotics or hormones uh it's
enough for 24 meals they pack it fresh
they ship it frozen for convenience so
you never have to go customize your own
box which i've done or you can go one of
theirs either way you get exactly what
you want this is your chance to never
have to shop for ground beef again
because that's right
butcher box is giving new members free
ground beef for life that's one of my
favorite promos they do you sign up at
butcherbox.com taste buds and you get
two pounds of ground beef free every
time you order for the life of your
entire membership just log on to
butcherbox.com slash taste buds and
claim that deal
yes can i tell you the difference then
between a california roll and a spicy
tuna a thousand percent of course yeah
okay so then you're telling me you could
tell the difference between a piece of
uh ground beef and a piece of steak you
close your eyes if you close your eyes
and i put a california rolled piece of
sushi roll in your mouth you would be
like this is sushi i don't know what
sushi it is if you put in a spicy sushi
roll you'd be like this is a spicy sushi
roll i don't know why i don't know what
kind of sushi you're eating if you're
going just plain tuna with rice around
it you're an amateur but i'm getting a
dragon roll
dude get any dragon rule you want if you
close your eyes
put a piece of sushi in your mouth i
swear to god right now i will make a
monetary wager if you were blindfolded
any way you want to compare california
and i would make you and i would i would
make you a monetary wager that if i gave
you a nacho with beef and uh a guac on
it versus a macho with steak and guac on
it you wouldn't be able to tell that
difference because there's a consistency
difference so then i can that's part of
the whole thing oh god there's no
consistency difference in sushi is there
why are you arguing that that's inherent
to what i'm saying i disagree that
there's no consistency you love sushi if
i put a blindfold on you you would never
be able to tell what
the difference comes from the
ingredients
that's what i'm saying there are people
that love sushi that's still going to me
still going to a sushi restaurant and be
like please no eel
no eel sauce i don't want mackerel i
don't want this so what this is going to
do it the people getting nachos say no
sour cream no guac
what was that yeah
do i have to say every time i order
nachos tell me right now is it the
cheese sauce or the cheese actually
melted you know what happened
seven out of ten times when i asked the
waiter or waitress that question they go
um
i don't know what's the difference what
happens
because it's a [ __ ] food that is thrown
together that is most of the time served
with zero
for quality if it's a [ __ ] food then let
me take this i love him it's good to
also poison you as dandy algalli says
nachos are for pigs you want to shove
their face with chips until they can
anymore sushi is for the sophisticate
that actually wants to appreciate and
enjoy everybody well that's what i'm
about to say let me put a mirror up to
you for all the times that you tell me
that i'm choosing the uppity the uppity
choice yeah because
you're in the table
the tables
the pig himself
choosing the sushi pip where are we at
time well
we're at 18 minutes right here oh that's
it yeah babes
settle into this
i do want to hop on south side because
you can have beer with nachos you can't
have it with sushi of course you can
drink
something yeah japanese beer with sushi
yeah
i mean it doesn't go like nachos ghosts
but also think of the problem
stop it it doesn't go like nachos
they get the run of the think of the
most average place or the most common
place that you would have each meal
right if you're having nachos you might
be at like you know
a bar a grill a place where you're maybe
watching sports or you're in a communal
celebration it's shared food it's it's
it's it's it's social it's it's uh it's
fun it's a fun dish everyone when the
nachos come everyone's in on the night
that's fine everybody's disgusting
fingers into your plate that's a lot of
fun but awesome like they pointed out
like they pointed out on i think you
should leave somebody's always taking
all the good chips that always happens
with nachos i personally don't like to
share nachos personally i like to go my
own route so because i'm not here for
you to figure out which chips are right
i love i love the art of eating a nacho
i love picking up a chip maybe that
one's bare and i decide how much of what
ingredients go on let me finish
i love searching through to see a
triangular nacho chip that has been
coated in melted cheese whereas and i'm
eating that one that's going to be a
loaded up one i like it i like some that
has sour cream on it some doesn't i like
grooting through the bottom pulling a
chip out with a surprise on it i like
that each bite might be weighted more in
the direction of each of the ingredients
so not all the bites always feel the
same i like the journey that i take when
i'm eating a nachos i like those options
i like that i like sushi let me give you
eight pieces of identical things no but
who cares identical who gets one roll
you get multiple rolls and you okay so
two two with eight identical pieces i'm
gonna cut it it sounds that is such a
lame argument you were so wrong i get
excuse me when i go i get a spicy roll i
get something with avocado something
with mango yes i change it all up i get
some that are topped with things maybe i
get a tempura yeah
cut six to eight of the same exact same
matter you hop around the plate and you
gotta order three different things oh my
god i don't gotta hop anywhere
a garbage man like me okay okay now
where is the place that you typically
typically will be getting sushi maybe
not the regular person maybe not some
upscale place it's usually especially
like where we're from in new york
there's a sushi place on every couple of
corners it is your standard sushi place
you ever walk into those places i
hate the standard sushi restaurant the
the the the park they're not as good as
those uh
those
metal counter mexican joints
uh that are that where everything is
thrown together you walk in you can't
even sit down those are great you walk
into a par sushi place god damn it
there's some type of crazy music playing
this euro house playing they always have
the lights too dim they trigger what
you're talking about maybe there's a
fish tank that's that'll give you a plus
but also isn't that a bit morbid
sushi i can already tell from the
comments i'm going to lose this one
again sushi is like jazz for people that
want to look and sound smarter than they
are i mean
philistines
just philistines writing in you're right
guys
you're right you're right nobody eats
sushi because it's delicious people
answering nachos are just picky children
sushi has a hundred times the variety
that nachos offer and it literally the
tastiest healthiest food on earth hold
on courtney says very strange match-up
but if joe takes nachos and sal takes
sushi joe will accuse him of classicism
sure well it's true i would have
are you looking out are you looking at
the man in the mirror shimon 100 against
jesus christ you see from the corner
store just not the
read
[Music]
sushi from
he wrote your he corner store so i
changed it to his to make up for this
person first part of this sentence was
in your in your in your intro just so he
can feel something when he pulls down
his whitey tighties it's tighty whities
actually that's that's shiny
yeah i know
jesus
[Music]
oh i'm sorry i'm not as sophisticated as
you are whitey tight skulls grow up a
little bit a little more
i did nachos are a way of life
the men full of wisdom who are fortunate
enough to bless their taste buds with a
punch of flavor nachos crates makes it
the clear winner
okay both when
combined
oh what is that
turn your scraps into tasty snacks oh my
god okay
only joe derosa would compare these two
an entree versus an appetizer health
versus junk not true hey guys how about
take a shot at sal once in a while you
suck-ups yeah you
suck-ups i will agree though guys jesus
christ crappy's too quick to judge the
matchups we have reasons to the madness
methods i would eat nachos every day if
i could i know lactose intolerant people
who would eat nachos every day and load
up on the cheese and not even care all
right here's the salad i agree i could
eat nachos almost every day i cannot eat
sushi almost every day here's this you
could not eat nachos almost every day
you would be three thousand pounds
i mean by by by preference i could like
you pizza here's a great one here's a
great thing
this is a good salad
g i wonder how the midwest heavy follow
based salad is gonna vote this one it's
a good point well we don't go i mean
scroll up one second
sorry people have only the palette for
garbage cheese and chips
nachos
are fine but sushi's an experience yes
i prefer nachos because they're easier
to taste good i've had crappy sushi way
too much
to vote for it
you should also
what ballpark do you know that serves
sushi in a souvenir helmet
that's very funny
uh you've probably heard about peloton
before if not for this uh this podcast
than in life because they are killing it
i have a peloton uh in my home i got it
a few months ago and i feel part of a
community now wow
i have my favorite uh instructors
uh i got my my weights attached to it i
put all my little boots my little
peloton shoes i click in i throw on the
headphones and that's it i i sometimes i
drive around new areas do you know that
you could drive around different cities
and areas it's cool it's for someone so
someone like me that needs help like
being distracted while i go through it
you're focused on the class you're
focused on the instructor or the sites
and you kind of get through it there's
new classes now there's new music so
much new there's new ways to keep your
workouts fun and motivating um
so they do have a bunch of new they're
always updating the classes and the um
the instructors it's fun and you have a
profile and it makes it almost like it
almost feels like when i play video
games i got my stats on there it tracks
my progress and it like quantifies what
i'm doing so i don't just like get off
the pedal time like all right i worked
out i kind of can see
my results i see how i improve on the
classes i take i like it a lot uh new
additions for the year the boxing
peloton is stepping into the ring with
its new newest discipline no gloves
needed uh
even if you've never boxed before these
classes will have you working up a sweat
while working on fundamentals of form
footwork and fun combos i have yet to do
that and it's something i want to try
because i'm not sure i know how to throw
a punch
[Laughter]
the new artists series music selections
um they're adding new artist series
classes you work out to the music of a
single artist for an entire class or
from your favorite hits to deep cuts pop
rock hip hop edm not for me but god
bless
uh and there's more daily workout
variety
which keeps it interesting pelton has a
workout for every goal every day every
mood de-stress from a long day with a 30
minute strength or 20 minutes of cardio
or do a quick 15 minute total body
for a limited time guys try the peloton
app for
free for two months then 12.99 a month
if thereafter new members only visit one
the number one spelled out
o n e peloton dot com
slash app to learn more that's two
months free at
o n e p e l o t o n dot com the offer
expires january
january thirty first twenty two and
terms apply
baldy i'm ballsy you're ballsy we're all
ballsy
ballsy is a new product line for men
that keep
their feet clean psych
they keep your balls clean
it's not called feetsy
um
ballsy they got a pr they got deodorants
colognes scrubs washes powders they got
trimmers everything for you to be your
best
below your dungaree you know what i'm
saying
you know and i hate you know sweat is my
second most hated thing it's traffic
sweat the common cold strong winds bugs
cats pointy objects and general filth
sweat i sweat everywhere
me personally i'm a germaphobe i like to
clean everywhere
ballsy is made for people like us that's
why you gotta check it out it's men's
products for men's parts
uh
they got your sack covered with ball
wash sack spray and more
i never i will never get over all these
i love the ball cologne the ball cologne
get yourself some ball cologne
um
[Laughter]
whether the guy who loves to trim it up
around there and uh or the guy who is
into self-care
you look fresh you smell fresh no bs
ingredients they're only made from
essential oils and plant extracts
there's no parabens sulfates dies none
of that stuff they don't test on animals
you can order in bundles they call them
sack packs
when in doubt get it all get the
ultimate sack pack
if you're not sure where to start you
can go on and take a fun little quiz and
it'll tailor the the the the thing to
your
exact watch got it they write it i'll
i'm gonna say it
uh made in the usa that's another big
one uh and they always will be
there's gift sets and the guarantee with
over 200 satisfied customers uh 200 000
satisfied customers and a 30-day
money-back guarantee there's nothing for
you to lose uh
ballsy we we use it and we're ready for
anything every day you know they always
say that only the house without clean
underwear don't leave the house without
clean everything and ballsy if you want
to take that you want to make it your uh
your thing 10 is all i want
uh speaking of percentages keep the funk
off your junk right now if you go to
ball wash.com
slash taste buds 20 and put in the promo
code tastebuds 20 you'll receive 20 off
that's 20 off plus free shipping when
you go to
ballwash.com tastebuds 20 and then put
in that promo code of tasteputs20.
that's very funny but
but mr byers
if you've ever stepped into the uh
what's it called at the yankee stadium
the gentleman's club not the gentleman's
club yeah like the uh the the legacy
club or whatever i got sushi all through
that [ __ ] i know but that's the new
yankee stadium yeah that's great nachos
because i'm obese shitty nachos are
still eligible shitty sushi you get food
poisoning okay i agree that shitty sushi
can give you food poisoning any food
made you could get hold on a second i
gotta make a point here hold on a second
i gotta make a point any food that is
not properly prepared can give you food
poisoning you can get food poisoning if
you know what they mean no stop if sushi
is high alert so then don't go to a
terrible place that you can't trust the
sushi people have gotten food poisoning
from fish and nice establishments that's
that's it's
argument someone says this is impossible
which speaks to the point that we think
this is an amazing battle who we don't
know who will okay and by the way i love
the people that are going sushi could
make you have to [ __ ] as opposed to the
mexican nachos
covered in beans that are literally the
punchline to every fart joke that has
ever existed but you're right guys
sushi's gonna make you [ __ ] i don't need
to see people you should get neither
from a gas station true i don't
understand this matchup at all well just
wait i've always also never had great
nachos never
i feel bad for you jack mike jack
which person chooses nachos with squirt
cheese over sushi disgusting i don't eat
squirt cheese
only if nacho's a 70 queso see that's
the thing you're calling it you're
calling it cheese whiz but a lot of
times it's queso
queso is different queso you were only
ever compared you were only getting real
queso in a tried and true mexican
restaurant most places that sir are no
i'm sorry not most many places that
serve nachos like your average bars
okay where most people get their nachos
you that is not queso that is [ __ ]
cheese whiz on your nachos
most of my places i i see i don't see
people putting cheese was on it not
7-eleven
i i go to the movies i get nachos
are using that same cheese a lot of the
time which is why i'm in the house
about the movies where they give you a
bag
and they give you a pre-packaged heated
up thing that you peel off and dip it in
there that's not nachos what i'm telling
you is i have experienced that cheese on
nachos enough times that i have to ask
okay here we go another another dig go
[ __ ] yourself
is back ladies and gentlemen the uh but
i mean seriously why listen to the
podcast if you hate half of it so much
loser then don't listen anymore how
about that don't listen anymore you
suck
it pretends to be classes but when you
really break it down it's just gross how
the [ __ ] would you know anything about
me
you [ __ ] turd
oh boy
[Applause]
yeah
honeymoon's over folks
the sucker is back and he's not leaving
i'll watch this podcast burn to the
ground before i leave
[Laughter]
i [ __ ] hate seafood
[Laughter]
sushi is underrated and underappreciated
i don't know if that's true at all uh
sushi but the smell of the movies would
be wild though
what
wait that's because he's saying you can
get nachos
you smell sushi at the movies yeah but
dude that's what i'm saying you can't
get sushi at the movies that's very
funny that he said the smell of the
movies would be wild that's very funny
oh that's that's a go up one that is
crazy i'd rather take chances on gas
station sushi than eat bottom of the
plate of mushy nachos
colleen you're off the residence i like
the bottom of the plate nacho when it's
oh i wouldn't eat the clumped up cheese
the cheese gets hard i want to meet the
person who purchased gas station sushi i
want to meet him
the uh sushi is the trend sam who is
that
s this woman woman says it's a trendy
food everyone secretly hates i literally
don't know one person that hates sushi
except my dad who's scared to eat it and
guess what he's 75 years old my dad is
of course he does that pig
all right just know that if you voted
against sushi you're with that pig to
stefano pimp our winner in that in the
tweets obviously is uh
what was the one that made us laugh so
hard oh the bucket of the helmet of
nachos yeah that was so good i don't
know where the hell that is
let's oh wait was that it was that a
picture of a helmet with nachos in it no
no he didn't put a picture
god that guy's saying i've never ever
had great what is your question there it
is right there when you pass it when you
order either of these right
when the waiters follow ben buyers three
b-e-n-b-y-e-e-r-s number three
wait let me answer this when when you
order when you're at either of the
establishments where you're ordering
either these dishes all things
considered they're good dishes
when do you get more excited when you
see the waiter walking over
with with a hot plate of nachos or do
you get more excited when you see the
waiter walking over with your sushi
rolls on a slab of uh rock
listen nice slab presentation of sushi
is i get so excited when it comes out
that's true it's not a fair question but
when you see it you go oh
i get equally excited when i see my food
in any restaurant circumstance no matter
what the truth is that i ordered okay
i can't i couldn't tell you i mean you
know it's it's when i see my food coming
out because i'm usually at the point of
i feel like we're going to pass out i
haven't eaten all day because i'm i've
i'm terrible with my food scheduling
i'm so excited you know what's very
unique in this matchup neither food uh
calls for traditional utensils
one is a hand food and one is chopstick
food i'm surprised we haven't seen
anyone rail on like oh i don't know how
to use chopsticks or oh i don't like
eating with my hands that is interesting
that is interesting where are
we're at 30 minutes here all right great
let's let's let's see the vote are you
ready all right you want to go you want
to go home apply i know i know we have
something to do today i think we really
we really got into the battle right away
i think we really gave it a one two hell
of a battle
i'm screaming at fans over here yeah oh
yeah you went off the deep end i love it
dude yeah let's get that whole rant
beeped but for a promo yeah yeah yeah
yeah ready yes all right uh
drum roll it is the humble ply segment
and by the way 9 000 votes so we crossed
8 000 on all three ups yeah but this was
quick because you only put this up like
yeah like 30 minutes i will tell you
this i i said it i thought christmas had
a less let's talk about the last couple
weeks though christmas had a slight
evangel birthday in my heart of hearts
last week i truly didn't know about
morning or evening i just didn't know
and i will say right now i truly
don't know
this i thought sushi was dead in the
water then as like we kept reading
comments i'm like maybe it's got a
chance
ready i don't want you to come back and
and three losses in a row three weeks in
a row what are you gonna do i'm not here
to win
i'm here to represent okay all right i'm
also trying i don't think i'm here to
win two though all right fair enough
here we go what is your preference drum
what are you what are you saying pimp
oh wow
all right
all right the numbers are in folks i'm
not even mad i don't care anymore i'm
numb to it it's a nachos win at
68.7
to sushi's 31.3
not as big a margin as the last few
weeks still a very very big margin
joe you took some time down you came
back and man you need you are in what
the they call a slump my friend
you need to be rejuvenated and
revitalized you need a horse in this
race that's going to bring you back to
life this is like the beginning of a
major league
this is brutal dude i gotta get my wild
thing out here
all right buddy
come to joey rose's 174 remington if
you're in new york city go to
joeyrosesnyc.com
for all hours and information
that's it for me babes
savilecanocomedy.com i'm on tour right
now i'm adding dates uh nashville
tennessee at the ryman is march 11th i
know that's a new date that is on sale
right now uh but all the dates are on
the website also community app babe goes
right to my phone text me 718-260-6619
do us a favor if you haven't subscribe
to our youtube channel nopresh
click the follow buttons on on spotify
and and on itunes and if you're so
inclined if you have a moment and if you
like the show give us a rating it all
helps uh we want to start banging that
drum because some of you guys are
probably ardent supporters but haven't
done that and that's a big help and
thank you guys for listening we hope
that you enjoyed today's battle which
was a bit all over the place but i loved
it uh we're good right it was a great
battle i gotta say it again yeah i got
uh new dates i can't remember these are
in the in the lead in commercial but i'm
i have new dates in austin texas at the
creek and cave uh in may go to jodarossa
info.com for all tour dates and tickets
i still love you babe i love you too
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one